hi guys last time I talked about the
difference between fluency and
proficiency and today we're going to
talk about how to bridge that gap so I'm
going to give you five awesome tips to
bridge the gap between the B zone and
the C dough without further ado let's
get started
a tip number one step out of your
comfort zone once you find yourself in
the fluency zone normally you tend to
stay within that zone because you can do
everything in your target language but
if you want to keep expanding and
refining your language skills you have
to get out there and get out of your
comfort zone which basically means do
things that you cannot do now if we take
the four areas of language learning let
me give you a few examples if you have
been speaking about everyday topics now
get out there get a native speaker and
talk about things that are a little bit
more complex and that implies also a
certain kind of language um write essays
about things that once again are complex
and that you can discuss in a certain
way by using certain connectors or read
books that you haven't read yet work
about novels for example or about more
complex things about cosmology oh you
name it the important thing is that you
like obviously what you read listen to
podcasts or listen or watch
documentaries about things that you
haven't watched yet and you haven't
touched upon yet tip number two follow
the fun normally when you are in a
certain zone it you've been doing
certain things and you had fun doing
these things well that's awesome but
when you want to move from one zone to
the other
you should have keep having fun that but
at the same time do something different
than you did before in my example I use
the bi-directional translation to get a
foundation of the language but once I
have gotten a foundation of the language
well I move on to something else
because that kind of BEC bi-directional
translation is becomes a little bit
boring tip number three do things
progressively language learning I always
say the language ring is a not a linear
but it's a progressive process so you
have to make sure that you do things
that are progressively more difficult
for example
let's let's say for example that you
want to let's consider reading at the
beginning you can read something which
is really simple like language learning
material and then you can move on to
bilingual books and then to monolingual
books and then on on to newspapers and
things that are a little bit more
complicated you can do the same thing
for speaking at the beginning you can
talk about everyday topics which are
really simple then you can have a
specific speech about a specific topic
then you can do storytelling that you
can do describe images after concepts
and so on but in this way you're getting
out of your comfort zone in a
progressive way tip number four
understand deliberate versus natural
practice this is a very important point
normally we tend to associate language
learning with with books with dry
studying but that is actually not so
language learning is about life language
learning is about getting out there
watching movie with friends go out have
fun so I think the deliberate practice
the practice that is sit down and study
and practice is is great but it's just
one part of an journey you have to
integrate it with a more natural
practice let me give an example well
playing video games reading a book that
you like going out with friends and talk
about stuff these are all things that
are within the realm of the natural
practice and they are as important as
the deliberate practice what you have to
do is to balance the two step number
five which is more like a rule than a
step actually is be patient language
learning is a long road and in this case
bridging the gap between the B zone and
the see zone that is one of the longest
and hardest stretches out there so
actually imagine it like once again
climbing the mountain instead of looking
at the top and cursing the distance in
between you should focus on every single
step and enjoy the view every time
because every single step is one step
towards the summit where it will finally
appoint the flag and that will happen
one
if you keep doing all these things Oh
whew nine and thanks for watching and
I'm going to talk to you very soon bye
you